another common sort of Gloom
comment I get from people are saying
we're just screwed there's no hope
is well things like gpt4 are way too
complicated for a human to ever
understand and prove that they can be
trustworthy they're forgetting that AI
can help us prove that things work right
yeah and and there's this very
fundamental fact that in math it's much
harder to come up with a proof than it
is to verify that the proof is correct
you can actually write a little proof
checking code it's quite short
but you can assume and understand and
then it can check the most monstrously
long proof beverage generated even by a
computer and say yeah this is valid
so so right now
we we have um
this uh
this approach with virus checking
software that it looks to see if there's
something you should not trust it and if
it can prove to itself that you should
not trust that code it warns you mine
when did you flip this around
and this is an idea I should give credit
to Steve I'm 100 for so that it will
only run the code if it can prove
instead of not running it if it can
prove that it's not trustworthy if it
will only run and if it can prove that
it's trustworthy so it asks the code
prove to me that you're going to do what
you say you're going to do
and and it gives you this proof
and you a little proof that you can
check it now you can actually trust
an AI That's much more intelligent than
you are right
because you it's it's problem to come up
with this proof that you could never
have found that you should trust it so
this is the interesting point I I agree
with you but this is where Eleazar
yakowski might disagree with you his
claim not with you but with this idea
is his claim is a super intelligent AI
would be able to know how to lie to you
with such a proof
I'll Delight to you and give me a proof
that I'm gonna think is correct yeah so
but it's not me it's lying to that's the
trick my proof checker
which is a piece of code so his general
idea is a super intelligent system
can lie to a dumber proof checker
so you're going to have as a system
becomes more and more intelligent
there's going to be a threshold
or a super intelligence system will be
able to effectively lie just slightly
Dumber AGI system uh like there's a
threat like he really focuses on this
weak AGI the strong AGI jump with a
strong AGI yeah can make all the weak
agis think that it's just one of them
but it's no longer that
and that leap is when it runs away yeah
I I don't buy that argument I think no
matter how super intelligent an AI is
it's never going to be able to prove to
me that they're only finitely many
primes for example
just it just can't and and um it can try
to snow Me by making up all sorts of new
weird rules of deduction
that and say trust me you know
the way your proof Checker works is too
limited and we have this new hyper map
and it's true but then I would I would
just uh take that attitude okay I'm
gonna forfeit some of these this
supposedly super cool technology so I'm
only going to go with the ones that I
can prove in my own trusted proof
gesture then I don't I think it's fine
there's still of course
this is not something anyone has
successfully implemented at this point
but I think it I just give it as an
example of hope we don't have to do all
the work ourselves right this is exactly
the sort of very boring and tedious task
that is perfect to Outsource to an AI
and this is a way in which less powerful
and less intelligent agents like us can
actually
continue to control and Trust more
powerful ones so build AGI systems that
help us defend against other AGI systems
well for starters
begin with a simple problem of just
making sure that the system that you own
or that's supposed to be loyal to you
has to prove to itself that it's always
going to do the things that you actually
wanted to do right and if it can't prove
it maybe it's still going to do it but
you won't run it so you just forfeit
some aspects of all the cool things AI
can do I I've had two dollars of donuts
it can still do some incredibly cool
stuff for you yeah there are other
things too that we shouldn't sweep under
the rug like not every human agrees on
exactly where what direction we should
go with Humanity right yes
and you've talked a lot about the
geopolitical things on this on on your
podcast to this effect you know but
I think that shouldn't distract us from
the fact that there are actually a lot
of things that everybody in the world
virtually agrees on that hey you know
like having no humans on the planet
in a in a near future nah let's not do
that right you look at something like
the United Nations sustainable
development goals
some of them are quite
ambitious and uh basically all the
countries agree U.S China Russia Ukraine
they all agree so instead of quibbling
about the little things we don't agree
on let's start with the things we do
with Beyond and and get them done
instead of being so distracted by all
these things we disagree on
that Morlock wins because
frankly
molok going wild now it feels like a war
on Life playing out in front of our eyes
if you if you just look at it from space
you know we're on this planet
beautiful vibrant ecosystem now we start
chopping down
big parts of it even though nobody most
people thought that was a bad idea
always start doing ocean acidification
wiping out all sorts of species oh now
we have all these close calls we almost
had a nuclear war and we're replacing
more and more on the biosphere with
non-living things we're also replacing
in our social lives a lot of the things
which were so valuable to humanity a lot
of social interactions now are replaced
by people staring into their rectangles
right and I
I'm not a psychologist I'm out of my
depth here but I suspect that part of
the reason why teen suicide and suicide
in general in the US that
record-breaking levels is actually
caused by
again and so AI Technologies and social
media making people spend less time with
with actually and actually just human
interaction we've all seen
a bunch of good looking people in
restaurants staring into the rectangles
instead of looking into each other's
eyes right
so that's also a part of the war in life
that that we're we're replacing so many
really life-affirming things
by technology we're we're putting
technology between us
the the technology that was supposed to
connect us is actually distancing us
ourselves from each other and um
and and then we're giving ever more
power to things which are not alive
these large corporations are not living
things right they're just maximizing
profit
there
I want to win them more in life I I
think we humans together with all our
fellow living things on this planet will
be better off if we can
remain in control over the non-living
things and make sure that they they work
for us I really think it can be done
can you just Linger on this
um maybe
high level philosophical disagreement
with Eliezer yadkowski
bye in this the hope you're stating so
he is very sure
he puts a very high probability
very close to one depending on the day
he puts it at one uh that AI is going to
kill humans
that there's just he does not see a
trajectory which it doesn't end up with
that conclusion what uh which trajectory
do you see that doesn't end up there and
maybe can you can you see the point he's
making
and and can you also see a way out
mm-hmm
first of all I tremendously respect
Elias yukowski and his his thinking
second I do share his view that there's
a pretty large chance that we're not
going to make it as humans there won't
be any humans on the planet
and not to distant future and that makes
me very sad you know we just had a
little baby and I keep asking myself you
know is um
how old is he even gonna get you know
and and um I ask myself hey
it feels I said to my wife recently it
feels a little bit like I was just
diagnosed with some sort of um
cancer which has some you know risk of
of dying from in some risk of surviving
you know
uh
except this is the kind of cancer which
would kill all of humanity so I
completely take seriously his
um his concerns
I think um
but I don't absolutely don't think it's
hopeless I think um there is a there is
a
first of all a lot of momentum now
for the first time actually since the
many many years that have passed since
since I and many other started warm
warning about this I feel
most people are getting it now
I
I I uh
just talking
to this guy in the gas station their
house the other day my
and he's like
I think we're getting replaced
and then I think in it so that's
positive that they're finally we're
finally seeing this reaction which is
the first step towards solving the
problem uh second uh I really think that
this this vision of only running ai's
really if the stakes are really high
they can prove to us that they're safe
it's really just virus checking in
Reverse again I I think it's
scientifically doable
I don't think it's hopeless
um
we might have to Forfeit some of the
technology that we could get if we were
putting Blind Faith in our AIS but we're
still going to get amazing stuff do you
envision a process with the proof
Checker like something like gpt4 GPT 5
will go through a process no rigorous no
obligation no I think it's hopeless
that's like trying to prove there about
five spaghetti
okay what I think well how the the whole
the vision I have for success is instead
that you know just like we human beings
were able to look at our brains and and
they still out the key knowledge Galileo
when his dad threw him an apple when he
was a kid he was able to catch it
because his brain could in this funny
spaghetti kind of way you know predict
how parabolos are going to move his
konaman system one right but then he got
older and it's like wait
this is a parabola it's it's y equals x
squared I can distill this knowledge out
and today you can easily program it into
a computer and it can simulate not just
that but how to get to Mars and so on
right I Envision a similar process where
we use the the amazing learning power of
neural networks
to discover the knowledge in the first
place but we don't stop with a black box
and and use that we then do a second
round of AI where we use automated
systems to extract out the knowledge and
see what is it what are the insights
it's had okay and it's
and then we we put that knowledge into a
completely different kind of um
architecture programming language or
whatever that's that's made in a way
that it can be both really efficient and
also
is more amenable to very formal
verification
that's that's my vision I'm not saying
sitting here saying I'm confident 100
sure that it's going to work you know
but I don't think it's a chance it's
certainly not zero either and it will
certainly be possible to do for a lot of
really cool AI applications that we're
not using now so we can have a lot of
the fun that we're excited about
if we if we do this we're going to need
a little bit of time
that's why it's good to pause and put in
place requirements
um
one more thing also I I think
you know someone might think well zero
percent chance we're gonna survive let's
just give up right that's very dangerous
because there's no more
guaranteed way it's a fail than to
convince yourself that it's impossible
and not to try
you know any if you you know when you
study history in military history the
first thing you learn is that that's
how you do psychological warfare you
persuade the other side that it's
hopeless so they don't even fight
and then then of course you win right
let's not do this uh psychological
warfare on ourselves and say there's a
hundred percent probability we're all
gonna we're all screwed anyway
it's sadly I I do get that a little bit
sometimes from from uh actually some
young people who are like so convinced
that we're all screwed that they're like
I'm just gonna play game play computer
games and do drugs and because we're
screwed anyway right
it's important
keep the hope alive because it actually
has a causal impact and making it makes
it more likely that we're going to
succeed it seems like the people that
actually build solutions to the problem
seemingly impossible to solve problems
are the ones that believe yeah they're
the ones who are the optimists yeah and
it's like uh it seems like there's some
fundamental law to the universe where
fake it till you make it kind of works
like believe it's possible and it
becomes possible yeah was it Henry Ford
who said that
if you can if you tell yourself that
it's impossible it is
so let's not make that mistake yeah and
this is a big mistake Society is making
or I think all in all everybody's so
gloomy and the media are also very
biased towards if it bleeds it bleeds
and gloom and doom right so
um
most
visions of the future we have or or a
dystopian which really demotivates
people we want to really really focus on
the upside also to give people the
willingness to fight for it
and um
for AI you and I mostly talked about
Gloom here again but let's not remember
not forget that you know
we have probably both lost
someone we really care about some
disease that we were told was incurable
well it's not there's no law of physics
saying they have to die of that cancer
or whatever of course you can cure it
and there's so many other things where
that we with our human intelligence have
also failed to solve on this planet
which AI could also very much help us
with right so if we can get this right
just be a little more chill and slow
down a little bit till we get it right
it's mind-blowing how awesome our future
can be right we talked a lot about stuff
on Earth it can be great
but even if you really get ambitious and
look up at the skies right there's no
reason we have to be stuck on this
planet for the rest of um
the remain for billions of years to come
we totally understand now that laws of
physics let life spread out into space
to other solar systems to other galaxies
and flourish for billions of billions of
years
and this to me is a very very hopeful
vision
that really motivates me to to fight
them and coming back in the end
something you talked about again you
know this the struggle how the human
struggle is one of the things that also
really gives meaning to our lives if
there's ever been an epic struggle
this is it and isn't it even more epic
if you're the underdog
if most people are telling you this is
gonna fail it's impossible right and you
persist
and you succeed
and that's what we can do together as a
species on this one a lot of pundits are
ready to count this out
both in the battle to keep AI safe and
becoming multiple planetary species yeah
and they're they're the same challenge
if we can keep AI safe that's how we're
gonna get multi-planatory very
efficiently